l comment vous j'ai reçu ce joli petit
colis la part d'apple avec pas mal de
choses à l'intérieur enfin deux produits
sur tout ça on va regarder tout à
l'heure pas forcément ce que vous
intéresser de plus tout de suite mais
c'est quand même très intéressante et
surtout je dirais que le bonheur se
situe ici le bonheur je pèse mes mots
nouveaux macbook pro le tout nouveau
macbook pro qui vient de sortir
[Musique]
maintenant
non
[Musique]
mon macbook pro qui a pas vraiment plein
de choses
la toute première c'est un écran 16
pouces ça c'était vraiment attendu le
fait d'avoir un écran un peu plus grand
sur les macbook pro mac utilise les mac
pro depuis des années un nouveau clavier
lesquels via papillon était pas
forcément aimé par tout le monde y avait
quelques problèmes mais il ya tout
nouveau clavier il ya un retour de la
touche escape mais surtout on a un
produit qui est tout beau tout neuf et
qui qui sort le 9 ça c'est vraiment
intéressant l'exercé aujourd'hui va
consister à le déballer à lunch box et
laissez moi tant que je vais transférer
toute l'année de mon moment ces mêmes
pros aux nouveaux macbook pro l'utilité
tranquillement et je donnerai mon retour
d'ici quelques jours pour l'instant
garder faire ça la sagem bien lâche
apple il ya toujours une façon de faire
et façon d'ouvrir qui est très simple
très facile c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool et c'est toujours très
intéressant parce que il ya un travail
si vous voulez qu'il faut en terme de
marketing sur l'expérience que ce soit
au niveau du déballage du produit où que
ce soit au niveau l'utilisation donc ça
s'est vraiment bien
attention on pas ouvert ça commence à
sautron comme ça là haut je sens que ça
vient c'est marrant quand des matériaux
qu'ils ont mis là il ya un espèce de
toucher en relief intérieur plutôt cool
jamais en haut on arrive là directement
sur un macbook pro avec petite languette
pour venir relever l'un des mois saints
de ses amis je fais très attention parce
que certainement pas le faire tomber
ça c'est vraiment cool design by apple
in california on va retrouver le câble
de charge
on va retrouver ça qu'est-ce qu'on a là
dessous bien évidemment les autocollants
ça c'est un grand classique ça marche
bienvenue sur votre macbook pro le
macbook pro démarre automatiquement
lorsque vous relever l'écran ça c'est
vraiment cool
bon ça nous explique un petit peu les
rudiments étant déjà un utilisateur du
match une fois depuis très longtemps je
pense que je devrais relativement à m'en
sortir
ça doit être des cartes de garantie
toutes les informations ensuite blog de
charge
là on va pouvoir les payer comment suis
là comme ça tout simplement tu peux
lâcher mon doigt s'il te plaît lâche le
doigt de papa voilà ça c'est très drôle
travailler parce que là on a une espèce
de papier on est dans un sentiment de
papier recyclé
on reste dans l'idée d'apple l'idée
d'avoir effectivement le recyclage au
niveau des produits pour le coup le
papier du meutre se déchirer mais d'un
autre côté il est recyclé lors que vous
l'ouvrez vous
t ça se recycle donc bon c'est pas
forcément très très très grave bluff de
charges en usb c'est ici donc venir
branché ça ici il a directement et
ensuite j'ai fait le tour de la bad boys
est assez sommaire on retrouve
l'essentiel mais ça marche comment ça se
défait ce truc je suis sûr que c'est
très simple je suis 100 kg en tout cas
intuitif armes et voilà il suffit de
tirer sa ceux des clips s'en fait et on
récupère tac tac tac sort de là toi je
vais le mettre là ils veulent prêts à
être utilisés ensuite on arrive
directement à la bête
regardez-moi ça l'on attendait
normalement si je le lève là si je
réfléchis
comme ce que fait apple en règle
générale voilà ça c'est l'expérience
yale c'est facile on prend entièrement
jeu pour continuer là et tout semble si
je te l'a bien ça ses feuilles tout seul
ça se déshabille en fait un ordinateur
comme ça on retrouve vraiment les codes
1d macbook pro ici le collectif tout en
usb cc 100% gaz baisser prise jack
ça c'est cool car des jeux mais mon
macbook pro 15 pouces à côté macbook pro
13 pouces
on a une petite différence quand même si
je me positionne dessus il ya quand même
une différence
bon c'est normal on n'a pas le même
châssis on n'a pas la même taille
j'ouvre la bête on vient protéger
directement l'écran
ok cool et l'ours qui s'ouvre regardez
il va s'allumer directement ça c'est
vraiment cool vraiment faire face à un
backup que je sauvegarde je me faire une
taille machine gémir l'installer là ça
c'est assez intéressant parce que en
fait ce macbook pro là j ai acheté
l'année dernière et j'avais jusqu'à il
ya pas très longtemps un macbook pro de
2011 qui fait qu'en fait tu n'étais pas
en 4-4-2 techniquement en full hd post
ordinateur hal un petit peu avec j'avais
monté de 4 gigas de ram à 8 gigas de ram
et l'année dernière j'ai craqué parce
que mon ordinateur est décédé du jour au
lendemain et j'ai acheté ça j'ai appelé
apple et ils m'ont dit vous achetez un
produit henri flohr vous l'aurez demain
il est disponible en voulant voir très
rapidement et ça c'est cool
du coup j'ai acheté ce macbook pro la de
2018 15 pouces 16 giga de ram et que je
trouve qui est vraiment très très bien
et c'est ça qui était simple en tout cas
lorsque j'ai dû changer d'un macbook pro
à l'autre c'est à dire que je branchais
choisi une time machine et je transfère
directement
l'idée des marques comme apple c'est
l'expérience yens c'est l'expérience que
ce soit pratique que ce soit simple il
faut que ça marche parfaitement bien
qu'on va retrouver notamment au niveau
des différences voyez ce avant tout la
touche et skype on a une touche et skate
qui est là qui revient whissell macbook
pro 15 pouces vous l'avez pas c'est tout
en virtuel sur la touch barre à peu nous
a pris par exemple notamment que ça
allait servir avant tout aux
développeurs pensent qu'ils ont besoin
ont besoin d'une touche physique bon
pourquoi pas c'est vrai que ça m'a pas
dérangé c'est vrai qu'au début ça m'a un
peu surpris dit ok j'ai pas touché skype
mais franchement j'utilise
iman jamais et lorsque j'en ai besoin
toshiba ça marche ça macbook pro se
donner pour avoir un des bords plus fin
que ce qu'on a sur le macbook pro 15
pouces alors je sais pas si on va s'en
rendre compte comme ça là c'est le
macbook pro 15 pouces
hélas ces macbook pro 13 pouces je puis
vous assurer que les portes quand même
beaucoup plus fin entre le 15 pouces le
16 pouces en haut mais également sur le
côté ça permet à l'écran occupait plus
de place au niveau du châssis une taille
plus utiliser plus optimisée c'est
beaucoup plus joli mais une grosse
nouveauté que le macbook pro 13 pouces
de 2019
ce n'est pas de la vo 16 pouces avant
donc c'est forcément le match de pro 13
pouces 2019 alors le macbook pro 16
pouces est bien c'est que vous n'avez
plus le clavier papillon vous avez le
magic qui bordent
apple s'est appuyé sur ce qui faisait au
niveau des mac pro
moi j'ai testé tout à l'heure je vais
vite fait et essayer 513 vraiment
intéressant une fois de plus de 8 à vous
abonner dès maintenant comme ça vous
saurez tout sur le retour d'expérience
pétanque de prennent bien en main que je
m'habitue que je compare vraiment dans
premier autres mais en tout cas comme ça
je trouve que saint paul qui est
vraiment cool six haut parleurs 3
microns mais côté vraiment très sympa au
niveau expérience y est vous avez
ordinateur qui n'a pas du tout vibrer
lorsque vous à l'écouté de la musique ni
vraie maîtrise d'un point de vue
technologique pour qu ils pas de
vibrations au niveau 2 l'ordinateur en
tout cas très très peu il ya un nouveau
ventilateur une acidité toujours plus
performants toujours plus autonomes
équipe on coud et exactement au même
prix parce qu'on peut trouver l'année
dernière au niveau du macbook pro 15
pouces donc si vous pensiez à changer
vous l'avez toujours pas fait et bien le
même process pouces et vraie belle
alternative parce qu'apple a vraiment
joué le jeu allait de soi disant ok on
sort un nouveau macbook pro hockey
l'écran est plus grand au qu'il est plus
performant au petit lait tout mieux mais
par contre on à le vendre au mépris et
ça pour moi c'est vraiment bien
vis-à-vis du consommateur et il ya ça
aussi qui m'a été dépassé par apple
regardez comme c'est tout mignon en fait
c'est une protection pour le macbook pro
macbook pro l'hiver cela paul magnon pro
16 pouces quand commence à s'ouvrir
cette jolie petite bête faut-il avoir
fait l'ena pour y arriver d'être pas les
balles non par leopard leopard le bac
par le bas par les haut-parleurs par le
bas je crois que ça pro et c'est pas mal
en cuir quand on le voit comme ça on
dirait un tapis de souris tellement ses
fins et en fait non c'est une protection
pour en permettre votre macbook pro dans
pas si vous voyez vous allez c'est parti
à pour le poser sur une table ça vient
vraiment le protéger ça vient se
positionner idéalement à l'intérieur ça
s'est très mal le fait de voir je lui
mets là dedans
régis arrivait normalement je dois
apprendre à se passer mais il faut quand
même un petit peu forcé pour qu'il est
bien se caler mais au moins ça me
protège ah ouais c'est pas mal
idéalement positionné ça s'équilibre
tchèque a livré j'aime bien c'est assez
sympa je valide sais pas comment vous le
trouvez où moi je le trouve bien on a
exactement la même chose en terme de
design ya rien de bien nouveau n'y a
rien de révolutionnaire rien n'a été
inventé par apple là-dessus toujours la
touch barjou dit mise à part le
changement du clavier mais en fait on
s'en rend pas compte visuellement sa
peau est un peu frustrant les gens
hockey nouveaux macbook pro mais lorsque
vous regardez on s'en rend pas compte
mais d'à côté c'est un choix stratégique
de la part d'apple c'est à dire de
s'appuyer sur ce qui marche chez eux des
produits qui sont reconnaissables les
produits qu'ils mangent bien avec le
branding macbook pro qu'on va retrouver
ici c'est vraiment le même design
toujours améliorer apple conserve son
adn va toujours plus loin plus vite plus
puissant plus autonome plus performants
et en plus nous en montrer les paysages
très intéressant mais ça je garde pour
le test c'est à dire que dans la mesure
de votre macbook pro vous éditez que ce
soit sur logic que ce soit sur final cut
que ce soit sur photoshop et bien vous
pouvez utiliser votre épée de pro à côté
pour venir travailler avec dans un même
logiciel que ce moniteur externe et avec
votre stylet ça vous paraît vraiment de
venir travailler de façon plus précise
autre chose ça vraiment cool je vous
invite donc à vous abonner parce qu'on
reparle d'ici quelques jours de ce
nouveau macbook pro macbook pro 13
pouces jolie petite bête je pense que je
monte encore plus vite je pense que j'ai
monté encore mieux et je pense que la
productivité sera accrue grâce à cette
petite machine petite mais puissante
il faut que vous vous trouvez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
être tenté par ce nouveau macbook pro 16
pouces châssis qui est légèrement plus
grand écran qu'il beaucoup plus beau
plus performant plus autonome en tout
cas je trouve ça cool merci à vous deux
mois tous vos questions et
interrogations tout ce que vous lui en
bas à demain fait des gros becs tôt